Golani had a 10 million pound bounty on
his head because he had connections
affiliations to the al-Qaeda etc. and he
was wanted by the US. But that all
changed and he became handsome man,
strong man, strong fighter, strong
fighter before statements that have been
sent by Donald Trump. You cannot believe
this
stuff. This video was sponsored by
Muslim Master inshallah to build
confidence in speaker. Confidence is
very important. Confidence was one of
the things that led me to Islam. Not my
own confidence, but the confidence of
Zakay Ahmed as the confidence that he
had in his religion made me realize why
is he so sure about what he's speaking
and he made me listen to him
attentively. So guys, when it comes to
confidence and how to speak, you need
this in marriage, work, colleagues,
friends, giving da. So brothers and
sisters, many dice have also taken this
course inshallah. Please check in the
link below. Let's get straight to the
video.
Asalamaikum brothers and sisters and
dear friends. One man's terrorist is
another man's hero in many situations,
but it depends if you're America. Yes,
because America is strategically
consistent, not morally. And we can see
that once again with Golani. Golani had
a 10 million pound bounty on his head
because he had connections affiliations
to the al-Qaeda etc. and he was wanted
by the US. But that all changed and he
became handsome man, strong man, strong
fighter, strong fighter before
statements that have been sent by Donald
Trump. You cannot believe this stuff.
Brother sisters, subhan Allah. But this
video sisters in uh the media as you can
see broisters um Middle East eye
Jordan's king warned us against
assassinating Syria Shah before Trump's
meeting. So, US senator says Trump's
foreign policy officials may have
floated options of assassinating
President Ahmed al-Shara. But why did
they not? Would did they want to
assassinate him because he was involved
in al-Qaeda or whatever it is for the
matter? No. So, Jordis King Abdullah II
warned the US against assass
assassinating President Ahmed al-Shar
before the new Syrian leader met with
President Donald Trump. A US senator
said on Thursday, the remarkable
statements by US senator reveals by the
deep hostility towards Shara in some
circles of the Trump administration. So
it's not even about Trump or the Trump's
administration. It's Trump's
administration. So there's, you know,
internal conflict. It reaffirms Trump's
own statements that he has been lobbyed
directly by the foreign leaders to give
Shah a chance while he was his own
adviser are skeptical. I have been
concerned by some rumors that I have
heard in some foreign policy circles of
the administration though that one
option that's been suggested in
assassinating the new leader of the
Syrian government, Ahmed Al- Sharam.
Democratic Senator Gene Sha Shaheen said
in a Senate hearing on Thursday and
obviously this is based on you know
Syria Israel pulling the plugs they're
looking at you know what benefits the
region him there not there let's see and
obviously the the king Abdullah said one
of the things that was pointed out to us
by the king Abdullah was that a change
in leadership that of that kind would
create an allout civil war in Syria that
would not be good to take advantage of
the opportunity we have to move that
country forward Shane said so as you can
see strategic it's not morally of what
they've or whatever it is for that
matter. None of that. They go against
even their own principles of people who
they deem that had connections with
al-Qaeda that may have harmed them. In
the US, they say, "No, we don't care
even if they harmed us. No, we look at
the future, how it benefits us." Shaheen
met with King Abdullah in Washington DC
in May, suggesting that those
discussions may have taken place before
Trump uh cancelled sanctions on Syria
and Med Sharah. Shaheen made the remarks
during her questioning of Joel Raburn.
Joel Raburn Trump's nominee for under
secretary of state for the near east the
top middle east position in the state
department. The administration by
Shaheen is is remarkable given the
events of this week. Trump surprised his
own senior officials and Israel but
announcing he was lifting sanctions on
Syria. Then again as you can see it's
all about gains. And you know what's
really interesting guys in your mockyama
people making judgments and because of
this and that it's all about strategic
affairs how it benefits one even when it
comes to one to us as individuals we do
things of favors you know I'll do that
for that person because he might do a
favor back later on and this is what
Islam is so beautiful about the sake of
Allah when you do for something for the
sake of Allah it's nothing expected I
don't do a so a can give something back
to me it's purely for the sake of Allah
and we expect our reward from Allah
subhanaa tala and on your maka when
judgment is made judgment is not going
to be based on people's affairs or wants
or desires. It's going to be made based
on true justice, ultimate justice. It is
not possible that Allah created all of
us and that all this turmoil and
injustice and oppression is going to
happen. What the Palestinians are going
through and it's all going to be
forgotten. A day will come when true
justice will prevail. And if you guys
want to see the article on BBC, US
scraps 10 million bounty for arrest of
Syria's new leader sh. Yes. Okay. As you
can see, they the US has scrabbed 10
million 7.9 million pounds reward for
the arrest of Syrians de facto leader
Ahmed Al following meetings between
senior diplomats and representatives. So
as you can see guys when it's caus it
when it's it it benefits them on
whatever way format they turn a blind
eye and I'm just going to carry on
reading on this other article on the
Middle East eye. uh speaking to the
reports on air force one after the
meeting Trump showered praised on saying
he was a young attractive guy tough guy
strong very strong past fighter yes
subhan allah and the same thing that
happened with bin laden the CIA yes when
they needed the al-Qaeda bin Laden to
fight of the Russians yes okay soviet
Russia they were the mjahedin they were
the soldiers but the moment they did
something that the US did not like they
became terrorists etc whatever for that
matter And I'm not saying they were or
they not. I'm not trying to defend
anyone. I'm just saying that hypocrisy
and double standards. So Al Jani, that
man who once had a 10 million pound
bounty on his head, who was known as a
terrorist, is now today a handsome,
handsome guy. He's a young attractive
guy, tough guy, strong past, very strong
past, a fighter. He is. Let's see till
when that will carry on. Inshallah. And
brothers and sisters, you can see the
devil stands in hypocrisy. And at this
stage, we don't even know about Jolani,
what he's about. Again, we assume the
best. And again, you need to understand
something, brother sisters, the Muslim
rulers are under massive pressure. And
I'm not here to defend the rulers at
all. But the matter is not as easy as
you guys make it out to be. There's so
much at stake. And to see that, you
know, what's going You would say, okay,
why would Jolan shake hands with Trump
or this guys? There's so much going on
that one cannot even put their finger on
it. We ask Allah subhana wa ta'ala
inshallah that the day a true khalifa a
real Muslim empire comes back and where
millions billions of Christians and Jews
lived on the peace under that empire and
were defended. Till next time.